okay today I'm going to talk to you
about reducing unwanted energy transfers
so we're going to have a look at two
different types of reducing unwanted
energy transfers and look at real-life
examples okay
so the first one we're going to look at
is a process called lubrication so we're
gonna have a look at this specific
example right here which is meant to
show a bike chain right here so whenever
something moves there is normally or
usually at least one frictional force
acting against them and so when we have
this bike chain going around whenever
there's a point of contact we're having
an unwanted energy transfer so what
actually happens is due to friction
we're actually having energy which is
basically transferred to the thermal
energy store now this is not beneficial
we do not want this to be happening
because it means less energy is being
transferred in a useful way
so what lubrication does is it acts to
try and reduce friction and therefore
reduce the energy which is wasted to the
thermal energy store so what an example
of this is is let's say I've got some
oil so here's a little bottle containing
oil now the oil goes onto the chain and
as it goes around it reduces the
friction by reducing the friction it
also reduces the energy lost to the
thermal to the thermal energy store the
energy wasted so as a result we have
less of that unwanted energy transfer
okay the other example we're going to
look at is an example involving
insulation now before we look at a
real-life example in houses it's
important for us just
to understand the process of conduction
so here I'm just doing a little diagram
to help illustrate this idea so I've
just drawn here the particles in a solid
notice how they're really closely packed
together what happens in conduction is
let's imagine I start heating and heat
to this side of this object here now as
I heat this object basically this
particular particle here gets more
kinetic energy so more energy added to
the kinetic storage starts to vibrate
more that vibration then gets passed to
this next particle next to it and so on
and so forth passing all of that energy
down the chain so essentially yeah that
that heat that that yet transfers energy
all the way through the object and this
is described as thermal conductivity now
that was an example of solids where the
particles tightly particles are tightly
packed together in a gas where the
particles are much more spread out
there's a much lower thermal
conductivity so if the heat is less
easily passed throughout the substance
this is just due to the fact that it's
they're not the particles aren't
touching so it's so less heat energy is
passed from this particle to this
particle so unless the energy will go in
the kinetic store because as the heated
they vibrate more but less energy will
be passed on now this is important when
we start thinking about insulation of
buildings so all I'm gonna do now is I'm
just gonna draw a little diagram to
illustrate to illustrate cavity wall
insulation okay so all I'm drawing here
are the walls to a house so I'm just
drawing the inside of the house here so
there's the chit there's a chair and
here's a table so the here is inside
so this part here is insight and this
part here is outside so I'm just gonna
show this just outside the house let's
say we've just got a tree outside to
build in like this now in this
particular context my unwanted energy
transfer will be losing heat let's say
it's a it's a winter's day so it's quite
cold outside I want to keep as much of
that thermal energy inside the building
as possible so as a result I can have
these thing this this wall design
basically is built to have a cavity
between two different walls that's the
outer wall and that's the inner wall
this cavity literally just contains the
air now the rationale behind this is
basically if we think about - conduction
if some of the thermal energy can it can
go through the wall which it can quite
easily if there was just one wall a lot
of that thermal energy would be escaping
into the into the surroundings which
mean that's an unwanted energy transfer
be losing lots of that thermal energy
however if I have a cavity installed
there's this air gap in the middle and
the air gap reduces the amount of
thermal energy which is lost to the
external surroundings remember the
thermal conductivity of a gas such as
the air is really low so therefore so
therefore I'll be losing less thermal
energy if I have this cavity between the
inner wall and the outer wall of my
house it also helps to have really thick
walls as well because the thick of the
wall the slower the rate of energy
transfer so guys those are two ways of
reducing unwanted energy transfers
lubrication and insulation thank you